maybe it's a mom putting her baby's life
at risk or a dad stopping his son from
pursuing his dreams or maybe the parents
are just straight-up homicidal whether
they're letting loose with emotional
abuse or trying to give their kids a
permanent timeout these are the worst
parents in movie history Marvel dads are
the worst they lie to their kids
disappoint them and in some instances
try to murder them and they don't get
any worse than fan OHS the mad Titan
with terrible parenting skills
he's a purple warlord who wants to
annihilate half the universe but he also
fancies himself a father figure when
he's not murdering entire planets full
of people
he's busy adopting kids to join his
little death cult and by adopting we
mean killing their parents and
kidnapping them
the truth naturally life with Thanos can
be kind of traumatizing as he forces his
kids to fight each other in bloody
brutal duels he particularly enjoys
torturing his daughter nebula cutting
off her body parts and replacing them
with hunks of metal
he may have fond feelings for Gamora but
at the end of the day he throws her off
a cliff so he can get his hands on a
shiny stone when your rock collection is
more important than your own kids
it means you probably weren't cut out
for this whole adoption thing played to
perfection by Allison Janney in the
biopic I Tanya Levada golden is a
chain-smoking hard-drinking foul-mouthed
devil woman as the mother of ice skater
Tonya Harding she does all sorts of
horrible things to push her little girl
to glory she nags her from the sidelines
violently beats her and forces her to
skates so long that she pees in the rink
even when Tanya grows up levana keeps
going with the put-downs every look she
shoots her daughter is dripping with
anger and disdain she won't even tell
her daughter that she loves her probably
because she doesn't love anything except
her cigarettes later on she justifies
her awful behavior by saying I made you
a champion knowing you'd hate me for it
that's the sacrifice that mother makes
but really golden just drives her
daughter toward a life of abuse and
scandal at first glance ego the Living
Planet seems like the perfect dad he
saves his long-lost son Peter quill from
an army of bad guys he invites him to
live in a gorgeous paradise and he even
looks like Kurt Russell sure he hasn't
been part of Peters life for decades but
now they're reunited and ready for an
overdue game of catch
alas ego is a god-like being who wants
to spread his seed across the universe
in more ways than one his plan involves
planting extraterrestrial flowers that
will eventually transform entire planets
into extensions of his consciousness
until everything
is but he needs help carrying out his
plan in the form of another demigod with
similar powers so he goes around the
universe impregnating basically every
being he comes across when his kids are
all grown he brings them to his homeland
to see if they've inherited any of his
celestial abilities if they haven't he
kills them and leaves their remains in a
cave full of bones there are bad dads
and then there are straight up evil dads
Jack Torrance falls in the latter
category played by Jack Nicholson in the
shining Torrance is a writer and
caretaker at the mountainside Overlook
Hotel he starts off a little psycho and
just gets more unhinged as the film goes
on
and I'll puff and I'll blow your house
here that psychosis isn't good for Jax
son Danny who possesses the psychic
ability called the shiny that allows him
to see all the evil spirits lurking in
the Overlook but despite his powers he
can't keep his dad from going completely
insane grabbing an axe and calling it
over for some bloody father-son bonding
time Jack chases little Danny all over
the hotel and out into the snowy hedge
maze where the kid manages to outsmart
and escape his dastardly old dad and in
Jack's final moments he learns that
trying to kill his kid does not make him
a cool parent well actually it kind of
does life can be hard when you're an
introverted teenager who's relentlessly
bullied while developing scary psychic
powers a girl like that really needs a
mom to care for her and guide her
through those difficult times
unfortunately for Carrie white her
mother is an absolute nutjob who'd
rather stab her daughter with a
butcher's knife than help her figure out
highschool played by Piper Laurie
Margaret white is a psycho who wants to
keep Carrie as isolated from the world
as possible when Kerri has her first
period Margaret locks her in a closet
and forces her to pray for forgiveness
for wicked ways when she goes off to
prom Margaret does everything she can to
keep Carrie at home telling her all her
classmates will just laugh at her it all
culminates in a candle that showdown
when Margaret looks a little too happy
while trying to stab her daughter to
death check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorites topper coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]